(audience applauds)
Ladies and gentlemen
it's Jenny Mollen.
(laughs) I wanted to have a really dramatic reveal.
She loves a dramatic entrance.
I mean, my God.
I love a dramatic entrance.
You know what?
I feel like I have equated Zooms,
like when people hide or they are in that back screen,
to people popping up from behind the couch,
and being like, "By the way I've been here the whole time."
You are like, "Ah! What did I say?
"What did I do?"
(laughs) I've heard of it.
(laughter)
I'm such a fan of your dictator lunches Jenny.
It makes me feel so good as a mom,
and it makes me feel like I could do this too,
and I could step up my game.
And I know that it really makes a difference with kids.
Like, this stuff means a lot to them.
And I think you are showing us all something,
and he said it was an extension of your love.
Oh, did you say all that?
I might have, I don't know what I said.
I think he is just saying that
so that he can get out of making the lunches.
(laughter)
Yeah.
I really cannot make these things ever.
(laughs) Well, I'll just--
I'm just glad she does it and I don't have to.
Well, speaking of,
like, Jenny will you teach us how to do this?
We all wanna be like you.
Yes.
And be extenders of our love for our children.
I would love to take you through one.
I actually have one.
I happen to have one right here.
(laughs)
So what I've done today is,
I wanted to do a lunch that sort of spoke to, you know,
the happiness and excitement of this new presidency
and what's happening in our nation.
So, the dictator lunch that we are gonna go with today
is the new world lunch.
I like to give them all a name.
What I'm gonna start with,
I have some raspberries up top,
and this is like a trick that, I don't know.
I don't know how I came up with this,
but I took,
this is the Benadryl
(laughs)
syringe from just like your, you know,
your local Benadryl, children's Benadryl drip
that you have in the house.
Sure, local.
Not your international Benadryl, okay?
(laughter)
You have the right syringe.
No, you need to like,
yeah, the local.
You need the local.
You need to always go buy local.
So I'm gonna swish some yogurt
into each of these little raspberries.
It's kind of an easy way for them to eat the yogurt
and not have it all over themselves as well, so--
Jenny, I think my syringe might have come from the vet.
(laughter)
Okay, that works too.
That works too.
That just adds another level of excitement.
I'm gonna add (laughs) that's a huge syringe.
That's for a great thing.
We need one of those at home,
just to like scare the kids because,
(laughs)
just like, instead of a timeout, you just pull that out,
and you are like, "Don't mess with me."
That's pretty good, okay.
I mean, it's,
if everything about parenting,
isn't about like leverage all the time, you know--
Oh yes, that's leverage.
I'm so excited when there is like, I have some leverage.
(chuckles) And like the bribes.
I hate when I've run out of bribes in the house.
Urgh.
Okay, so for the next little compartment,
I love this PlanetBox.
They give me all these little nice compartments.
I have a unity salad.
I always like to push the envelope a little bit.
Like I know he might not eat this kale,
but I want the repetition.
I want him to keep seeing it.
because eventually I'm gonna win in the end.
(laughter)
Also color matters.
And whenever I'm like making a Bento box
or something for my kids,
I try so hard to balance out the colors.
Yeah, yeah and you know--
When you got like a red--
Speaking of color, I do have some little red parts
just for like the love and the N that's going on right now.
I feel like I'm feeling the love from everybody around me.
And I have some wasabi peas just to keep it interesting,
but I'm gonna hide the wasabi
with these little beet love chips.
All right, I've got beat hearts.
Okay, I mean, I'm going for a United States of America.
I have an American flag sandwich.
Yeah, hold it up a little bit.
Which for you guys I did the jam
because I think it looks prettier,
but I'm sort of hardcore
with the sugar that I'm putting in these.
So I probably, to be honest with you,
would have done SunButter instead of jelly
underneath these bananas.
By the way, I love SunButter.
This little guy is from a small business in New York,
a small little baker called Spots,
and I'm just gonna put him in the middle
because I love the compartment in the middle.
It's like, sometimes I just put goji berries,
sometimes it's,
I don't know,
a scoop of SunButter,
but today I love,
my favorite is when I have something that actually fits it,
and today I happen to have a cupcake on the end.
It's the--
So that's, you know, that's it.
There you go.
Everybody look at what Jenny inspired me to make.
(audience applauds)
I love that you name them all.
And obviously,
have you ever considered like a lovely coffee table book
for your kids when they grow up,
of every picture of these from your Instagram?
Come on, this is amazing.
Yeah, we love the aftershocks
of what my kids do to these lunches.
(laughter)
That's sort of my favorite part. (laughs)
(laughs) And they haven't seen the "American Pie" yet.
So what they do to the lunches is still PG.
Yes.
(laughter)
I heard you guys said
it's a good thing that you have boys.
Because when they see that,
believe me, I have things my girls are gonna see,
and they, you know, I've tried to like forewarn them,
but I'm like,
the reason I'm so like chased now
is 'cause I tried everything and I found myself here.
And how funny is that?
We love that.
Yeah.
I love that.
There is nothing but G rated left in us.
I totally get that.
(laughs)
I know, it's true.
All the R and the X is just gone.
(laughs)
That's so true.
Well, G also is for games,
and I love games so much.
We just had game show week on the show,
and I grew up watching them.
I'm a big fan.
Tell me everything about "Cherries Wild."
By the way, that was a stellar segue, Drew.
If I may say so myself.
(audience claps)
G is for games and G is for good transition.
Thank you.
(laughter)
(laughs) I'm obsessed with game shows.
I feel like when I was growing up, it was another great time
and I would stay home from school sick,
and watch "The Price is Right"
and all the daytime game shows,
and it was like, it was heaven for me.
I love games.
I love--
You get excited giving away other people's money.
I get very excited giving away other people's money.
And, (laughs)
(laughs) Yeah.
And yeah, I just,
you know, I felt like it'd be a fun fit for me.
And my good friends at Fox, you know, came to me,
and they had this great idea.
They are collaborating with Pepsi
for their Wild Cherry brand,
and they have the show "Cherries Wild."
It's a giant slot machine.
Crazy crazy slot machine.
And you got a pair of,
a pair comes on,
a team of two every episode,
and they do pop culture trivia questions,
to earn spins on the slot machine,
and they can win $250,000.
And it's crazy, and it's awesome, and it's fun,
and I had a blast,
and yeah, it was so much fun.
I'm really excited for this show.
I just think it's gonna be really huge,
and I am gonna be there on the theater.
And you know what you guys?
H is for host.
(laughter)
And I don't know how I got into this weird
Sesame Street letter transition thing,
(laughs)
but now I'm just riding it into the sunset.
And certainly,
Jenny, you get the letter M for best mom.
Oh, thank you.
Jenny Mollen, Jason Biggs!
(audience applauds)
Cherries.
Thank you Drew.
Thank you guys.
"Cherries Wild" there Sundays at seven,
six central on Fox.
(upbeat music)